[Music]
hey what's up guys that could be HD here
and this is it this is the one plus six
so it's been interesting to follow
oneplus for the last couple years all
the way from the beginning from the
oneplus one days the flagship killer
mentality that never settle and then
look at how the trends move all the way
until what they've developed into today
so let's look at the spec sheet first
this guy's rockin snapdragon 845 and
Adreno 636 or 8 gigs of ram a 6.3 inch
20 to 80 by 1080 AMOLED display he's got
a 3300 milliamp hour battery and dual
cameras a 16 megapixel main sensor and a
20 megapixel secondary camera and a
price tag under 600 bucks so again
pretty classic oneplus they're sticking
to their guns of delivering big numbers
and impressive specs for a lower than
expected price so with all that here are
my impressions and really what a lot of
people are gonna have the most strong
reaction to including me is the new
design of the 1 plus 6 so they just like
everyone else this year have 28 teen
eyes their phone it's got dual cameras
glass back big screen and a notch I mean
that's it that's just like every phone
we've seen in the last 6 months and
probably every phone for the next six
months so one plus joins that crew and
this is what their version of it looks
like and honestly I think it looks
pretty good I don't know if it's just
that I've been getting used to notches
and phones for the past few months or
maybe that this one's a little bit
smaller I don't know what's wrong with
me but I think this phone overall looks
pretty good the text and icons go right
up to the edge in the corners the bottom
chin is pretty small so it's not bad the
glass back is a little more interesting
it's got that signature one Plus curve
to it so it's the same shape as the rest
of their phones adds a little weight
though from being glass no wireless
charging though that's kind of a
turn-off but that's just the first
impression there's actually three
different glass back finishes a mirror
glossy back that kind of looks like a
ceramic a soft white with this rose gold
metal accent color and
yes a matte black kinda I mean it's much
more matte than glossy I'd say it has
this kind of a sheen to it in certain
lights it feels more like I describe it
like a frosted black glass but at the
end of the day I'm still gonna put a
deep brown skin on it just to hide the
fingerprints and add grip to what you
get with a glass phone but that's just
me but continuing on the back the new
fingerprint reader is in the same place
but it's a bit smaller so you might
remember it was a circle on the back of
the 1 + 5 t I liked that this one has
less surface area and sits right below
the vertically oriented dual cameras
that pretty much everyone is adopting
now this dual camera setup is actually
kind of interesting though usually you
just kind of assume when you have dual
cameras on the back of a phone you got
your main camera sensor and on the
secondary ones usually your telephoto
for portrait mode and 2x zoom things
like that these two cameras are actually
the same focal length so the primary
camera is a Sony IMX 5:19 a 16 megapixel
sensor with an F 1.7 aperture and oh is
and then your secondary camera is a Sony
AMX 376 K a 20 megapixel sensor again at
F 1.7 and they don't say whether it's
optically stabilized or not so I would
guess it's not so a secondary camera of
the same focal length but a higher
resolution for what sharpness maybe some
detail stuff I guess maybe portrait mode
helped I don't really know exactly this
is something we're gonna have to test
for the full review we definitely stay
tuned on places like Instagram and
Twitter we're all share sample photos I
take on this camera but that's a curious
one but around the front is really where
it looks the newest with that huge new
display the notch up top this is what
people love talking about to be fair is
one of the smallest notches there's just
a camera some sensors and your earpiece
up there and then you end up with an 84%
screen to body ratio but this is the new
design this is what we're getting in
2018 it's exactly what we expected so
okay we've get it oneplus has taken cues
and hints from 2018 and other players
and they've updated their smartphone but
they've also actually taken things from
what they've done well in the past and
they've stuck to their guns on things
like - charging on things like oxygen OS
they kept the alert slider they kept the
headphone jack and they stuck with 1080p
so I
os really is great you could barely call
it a skin but it's one of those few
skins on top of Android 8.1 that doesn't
try to do too much so it's near stock
it's always one of the first with
software updates and it has a couple
tweaks here and there to make things
interesting they still have this shelf
next to the launcher cool there's a
toggle to hide the top notch if you're
not super into that that's new to oxygen
OS and this time they've also added
gestures if you want to get rid of the
buttons at the bottom and fully maximize
your screen real estate and do swiping
instead I don't really like this as much
it's not quite as smooth as I would have
liked or anywhere near something on an
iPhone that's the reason I'm not using
it all the time but I think this can be
improved with software updates
they also tossed in some improvements to
the gaming mode as well there's a dark
mode theme which can do wonders with
that AMOLED display so yeah just a nice
little suite of improvements over the
mostly stock Android I'd say is my
favorite way to go and on top of all of
that it's got really good I just really
like these buttons there's really
tactile clicky buttons probably one of
the most underrated things about this
bluetooth 5.0 and that I mentioned it
keeps the headphone jack like this thing
checks a lot of boxes so basically these
cameras and the battery life are the two
things that need to be deeply tested but
I can tell you right now after I've used
this phone for the past couple days and
it is a really promising one it's fast
its smooth it has a lot of the things
well that I hope a phone does well and
it's just those last couple things that
we'll see about but for those you
wondering I will be doing a full review
of the oneplus 6 people were asking that
that's definitely happening but so far
so good
let me know what you think until the
next one thanks for watching peace